[موسيقى]
منذ نشاه هذا الكوكب والناس يتنقلون في
اراضيه كيفما ارادوا لكن ومع بسط القبائل
والشعوب نفوذها على مناطق محدده اصبح
ابراز الهويه اثناء السفر ضروره انتهت
بابتكار جوازات السفر فكيف حدث ذلك
يشير التاريخ الى ان البشر استخدموا طرقا
وادوات تساعدهم على تحديد هوياتهم خلال
العصور القديمه هذه الوسائل تضمنت الاختام
الملكيه واقنعه الوجوه والوشوم والورق
وكانت كافيه لحمايتهم اثناء السفر
في غرب افريقيا مثلا استخدمت اقنعه
القبائل فيما استخدم الاغريق الوشوم
السريه اما الورق فاقدم وثيقه سفر عثر
عليها تعود لنحو 450 قبل الميلاد وقد
منحها ملك الفرسي ارتحشست الاول لمسؤول
لديه لحمايته عندما اراد السفر لبلاد ما
وراء النهرين كما تقول وثيقه الارثى ان
الهنود استخدموا اول وثيقه سفر بالتاريخ
بين القرنين الثاني والثالث قبل الميلاد
خلال فتره الخلافه الاسلاميه منح دافع
الجزيه ايصال دفع الضرائب المسمى ورقه
البراءه ليتمكنوا من التنقل داخل دوله
الاسلاميه وذلك بين عامي
632 وال 1258
اما جواز السفر بشكله الحديث فاصدره الملك
هنري الخامس بانجلترا عام
تضمن هذا الجواز تحذيرات للدول الاخرى بان
تسمح لرعاياه بالسفر بحريه وان حامله
سيتمتع بسلوك امن
بدوره اصدر الملك الفرنسي لويس الرابع عشر
خلال القرنين السابع عشر وثامن عشر وثائق
مشابهه وموقعه منه شخصيا
واستخدم حينها مصطلح باسبورت لاول مره
وقصد به المرور عبر ميناء لان السفر كان
عبر البحر بالغالب في العصور الوسطى تم
اصدار جوازات السفر باوروبا للمسافرين
الاجانب فقط وكان يحتوي على قائمه مناطق
يسمح لحاملها بدخولها وكانت كشهادات من
صفحه واحده مختومه بشكل رسمي
انهار النظام الاوروبي بشكل غير متوقع اثر
انتعاش حركه السياحه بمنتصف القرن التاسع
عشر فالغي تماما بحلول العام
1914 لكنه اعيد مجددا بسبب تصاعد المخاوف
الامنيه وتزايد موجات الهجره لاوروبا التي
رافقت اندلاع الحرب العالميه الاولى
في عام
1980 قادت الجهود الدوليه الى توحيد شكل
جوازات السفر عالميا ولكن نصه لم يختلف
كثيرا عن خطاب توصيه الملك هنري كما تم
وضع المعيار الدولي لجوازات السفر
المقروءه اليا مع بدايه الالفيه الثانيه
وفي اعقاب هجمات الحادي عشر من سبتمبر دعا
مجلس الامن لزياده امن وثائق السفر وتم
اصدار جوازات السفر المقروءه اليا مع
المعرفات البيومتريه كما اوجب على الدول
المعفيه من التاشيره الامريكيه اعتبارا من
العام 2006 اصدار جوازات السفر
الالكترونيه توجد اليوم جوازات السفر على
شكل كتيبات ورقيه او الكترونيه بشريحه
بيومتريه لكن احدا لا يعلم لربما تنقرض
جوازات السفر الورقيه قريبا وتصبح رقميه
بالكامل او يصبح لدينا جواز سفر نا نو
مضمن في الجسم